this video is sponsored by King of
Fighters All Star King of Fighters all
stars are free to play old-school
side-scrolling beat-em-up based on the
king of fighter series yes if you're a
fan of King of Fighters you can now play
the latest iteration on mobile featuring
all of the characters from KOF 94 to 14
and have even just recently added some
Tekken characters for an absolutely
massive available roster that includes
all the fan favorites yes even the ones
that are for good boys and girls of all
ages well this isn't a straight-up
fighting game like the series is best
known for they've done a really good job
of creating a weighty satisfying combat
system that definitely feels like you're
playing a fighting game but honestly
looks really impressive for a mobile
game if this sounds like something you
want to try out click the link below to
download it on iOS or Android and anyone
who does download it you get a free five
star gin Cosma just by logging in and
with that said let's get on with the
video one of the longest-running feuds
known to man is that between the manga
reader and the anime fan for decades the
two factions have looked for a way to
coexist in peace but thus far for
negotiation efforts have been rendered
useless as neither has been able to find
a solution for the other side's problem
anime fans biggest problem with
margaritas is that they just want to be
left alone to enjoy a show in peace
without being spoiled or judged for
enjoying it in their medium of choice
and margaritas biggest problem with
anime fans is that they exist the
earliest documented instance of this
feud goes all the way back to 44 BC
during the assassination of Julius
Caesar from what we know of history
Caesar was assassinated by a group of up
to 60 conspirators where he puts up a
valiant fight until he saw one of his
closest friends Brutus was one of the
assassins stricken with grief utterly
aghast at the sight of a friend he
treated like his own son betraying him
dying in despair Caesar uttered the
famous phrase you too child and then
Brutus replied you would have known this
was coming if you read the manga today
we will be studying this conflicts
breaking down the reason this divide
exists so one day we will hopefully be
able to see if the two factions will
find a way to be able to live together
in harmony when we look at the two
groups one of the biggest reason for
conflict is the sort of perceived class
discrepancy anime fans hold on to this
notion that margaritas have this kind of
superiority
complex and think they're better in
every way and this might actually be a
misunderstanding because on the other
side's country to popular belief
according to margaritas they don't think
they are superior to anime fans at all
they know they are and to get to the
root of this reasoning we first need to
understand how both factions operate
internally if we look at the anime fans
they can be split up into groups
consisting of Shonen fans mecha fans
Idol fans seasonal goers Maui lovers
casuals hardcore elitist
cosplayers meemers sucker and 3GS
animators voice actors and that one
person is only seen Dragonball Z and on
the flip sides margaritas consists of
people who watched an anime than read
head of the manga and people who watched
an anime than read ahead in the manga
this gives what marguerita's deemed to
be a kind of superpower that gives them
the ability to see the future enabling
them to act as a sort of prophets always
knowing what will come next when the
anime fan won't they call this holy
ability for sites while anime fans call
it being an impatient prick and this is
where the root of the issue lies
margaritas just want to be able to
discuss the latest developments of a
story openly and share their excitement
of the newest chapters but of course if
they do so will face backlash from anime
fans who have not caught up as far as
them through this they've come to master
this secret technique called spoiling in
plain sight see in this current era
there is a certain etiquette when it
comes to spoiling people can be seen as
our souls if they are just straight up
posting spoilers especially on their
social media but margaritas have found a
way around this the trick is to only
leave cryptic messages that may Li hint
at future events but making sure the
hints are subtle enough that they can
only be deciphered by people who read
the manga and also people who are
watching the anime people who aren't
watching the anime people who don't even
know what anime is and pretty much
anyone who has a higher mental capacity
than the crippled ape suffering from
Alzheimer's and thus by spoiling nothing
they are able to spoil absolutely
everything
hence spoiling in plain sight let's look
at a case study of how this is done I
just really like that character oh oh
okay
why why are you saying you like that oh
no reason I mean I don't want to spoil
it for you or anything just just don't
just don't get too attached or do it's
your choice
he's an out-of-context image telling you
how foolish you are you know I'm not a
[ __ ] idiot right like if he's not
dead now I know something bad is gonna
happen
he's an out-of-context gift showing
someone crying when I think of that
character great now I know he's actually
dead oh you're overreacting I mean
there's no need to lose your head if you
know what I'm saying you don't know what
I'm saying
I didn't even know that could possibly
mean can you just stop you're pissing me
off and I don't want to say something
that could hurt you all right but just
so you know there's nothing you could
say that could possibly hurt Comey son
is never getting an animal you take that
back you little piece of [ __ ] this is a
peculiar phenomenon because of the
information discrepancy as in the
margarita knows more than the enemy fan
we can see them start to disregard
anything the enemy fan may have to say
oh you have a theory of what will happen
next ah that's cute oh you're so cute
when you think certain characters are
bad right now and the series hasn't done
well to develop them yet see in order to
have a fully formed opinion you need to
know all the available information of
the series in question thus manga
readers won't listen to the opinion of
anime fans until the anime has caught up
to the manga however this is a catch-22
as the manga will always be ahead of the
anime therefore the conclusion we can
draw is that anime fans just shouldn't
have opinions this effect is seen in
full force when a discussion comes down
to which medium is the superior way to
consume a series while anime fans are
able to consume a show as a passive act
margaritas are stuck in a constant state
of spot the difference whereby they will
make a mental checklist of every little
scene cuts every piece of dialogue that
is different and this can hinder their
opinion of the show this puts any
adaptation on a tightrope where manga
readers have a subconscious expectation
of how the anime will play out and the
smallest thing can offset this
negatively from the voice acting not
sounding as dramatic as it did in their
head to the anime not using the exact
track they had searched up on YouTube to
play when they were reading the scene in
the manga
please tell me this is let's the famous
phrase the manga was better a winning
statement that can be used in any and
all situations to trump any opinion that
may be said about franchise and is the
closest thing the anime and manga
community have to a real life reverse
you know guard well you know I thought
the anime was good when I watched her
the manga was better look I just prefer
having movements color voice act music
and I didn't have a problem with how it
was handled the manga was better I mean
this was an anime original show and it
didn't even have a manga
the manga was better which begs the
question was the manga actually better
well even for the most stubborn of anime
fans it is impossible to deny that manga
has a lot of examples with many
advantages currently reading the One
Piece manga is the only viable way for
newcomers to a hundred percent speedrun
the series often times the manga
continues the story far beyond what the
anime can and there are a few series now
universally agreed that should only be
consumed in manga form like Tokyo ghoul
for example people swear by the Tarkio
ghoul manga and for a pretty obvious
reason that's right the manga sex scene
was way more detailed on the anime
completely changed everything but
whatever this concludes all the
available information that could be
found at this moment it should be noted
that it is rumored that this type of
margarita is simply the vocal minority
and that most people actually enjoy both
anime and manga and there may be even
some manga readers who actually read
manga that don't even have a
corresponding anime adaptation but it is
often impossible to discern them in the
shitstorm that gets left behind during
any conflict scene in a public setting
until then anime fans will continue
wondering why another group of people
would want to look down on them for just
enjoying a show in their medium of
choice who will then continue turning
around and laughing at anyone who
decides to watch dubbed anime while we
did not find a solution to how to stop
the ongoing feud between the two sides
we can still hope that one day the two
factions may be able to find some common
grounds they finally agree on so yes
that's it there's just nothing we can
agree on yeah I guess you're right hey
guys how you do get the [ __ ] out of here
go why are you here neither of us likes
you [ __ ] off what an awesome right
I know right
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to King of Fighters or
star for sponsoring me today if you want
to get in on some old-school
side-scrolling beat-em-up action then
you click the link in the description to
download it today and with that said
thank you very much to Ella for Robert
and Borg Basel Larkin and everyone else
my picture on for helping to sponsor me
this month
hope I'm not overloading you guys with
too many sponsorships recently I've just
had to take on a bit more this month to
offset the cost of me moving countries
setting everything up here and also the
time I took off from making contents
last month but hopefully everything
should be back to normal soon so I just
want to thank you guys for sticking with
me through this transition in my life
and just my general degeneracy so anyway
that's it for me I don't have any more
updates for you today
I've been gigging and I'll see you all
next time